did go Knight E4 because as I mentioned
there really isn't very much Choice
again instead of Knight E4 but did not
play C5 because C5 does more or less
completely force you to play the kinds
of positions that we were describing so
he got he got C6 here E3 castles
yeah okay this exists and uh it's not
horrible at all but it's not supposed to
be as
comfortably equalizing you know but yeah
it looks simple board in the meantime
and Chad tells us that uh Magnus is
following his own game against Nakamura
from Bill 2012 which is once again yeah
more grunfels dead to get the game
simply yeah and this is what I sort of
expected just some kind of queen A5 and
then you go for this plan of uh 97 and
then if you really have a lot of time
you would maybe even like to play B5
Knight B6 B6 to really get a grip on the
C4 square but you normally don't get
this much time so you play 96 P6 and uh
another thing that white needs to pay
attention to is you would like to
preserve the bishop pair but then you
might have the sacrifice on C3 which is
probably not something that Winston
would and on the subject of avoiding all
of those night jumps uh Winston starts
with Bishop G5 which I like quite a
quite a lot because attacking the ball
only seven when the queen Ventures away
from the eight is a very very standard
thing which is extremely annoying in all
kinds of beautiful positions
and Magnus now has to be
um
very careful because you you can very
very easily drift into positions you
will hate quite a bit
fantastic yeah
just a very nice Greenfield so he did
play B5 he did play rookie 8 as we were
sort of expecting and 96. I'm not sure
how I feel about the movie four here
but I also don't know what else to do
because
we're not in time to play A4 as far as I
can see and then yeah it's it's unclear
where our pieces are supposed to go but
I don't know if Bishop D7 is a mistake
which B7 also looks very playable
like rook ac1 and then I don't know
Knight A4 Queen A4 or just a waging move
or even these things maybe in some
positions and Bishop G4 is played it
before played very quickly yeah no I
thought it was a decent idea Bishop
digital played by bits and Camera some
prophylactic
uh move
okay
but now I'm curious maybe even the
immediately six is quite strong yeah
this is shaping up to be a very very
nice position for minions triple more
Champion
I think he's doing really well I think
this is yeah this is a dream ground
filled by this point like an absolute
dream field uh you generally like
there's this really quirky line in uh
that I think Russian panamari if maybe
was one of the earliest people who did
this there's this line uh no I think uh
this is the moon version right
uh where basically at least one of the
ways to play it would be to Castle play
G5 Queen E6 and then after Knight F3 the
idea is to play Bishop G4
let's say HP 297 and very often you are
actually trying to do this and then B5
Knight C5 and 96 uh but what Magnus is
getting in the game is like a place but
on steroids like
very very very far advanced in terms of
Tempe because white is not going to get
uh White is not going to get uh anything
going yeah uh on the king side like
eventually I guess you have to take only
six we take but the Roku I suppose and
we want to play Knight A4 we want to
play okay E8 there is already we dealt
with the pawn pair in the center which
is never going to move forward
there is actually pressure against the
E4 Pawn there is always pressure against
the C3 Pawn yeah yeah this is going to
go quite poorly I think for for winter
yeah and it can be as well very fast
should be possible to find the move yeah
so it took only six obviously yeah what
else can you do what else can you do to
play hog theater
as well yeah yeah hook d8 hook D3 maybe
I will D6
for sure so good for Lucky but yeah so
Knight D4 Bishop hockey six display 94
will be played yeah I think you have to
play 94 I think it should be 292 and now
it's you have to be precise here yeah
you have to stop 94 from coming back
yeah you have a thread I will respect
your threat
and then I will play Queen A4 okay and I
will win this end game yeah uh what can
I say yeah yeah this is nice yeah you
have a thread it's a threat I will I
will treat it with respect it deserves
aimed aimed his Knight at the D3 Square
straight away and once it's there you
can even in some cases just sacrifice in
exchange for this guy like some line I
mean understand that this is just a very
sample type line with like something
like this
and next move I will just take on D5
and then it will be impossible to stop
the The Invasion along the e-file I mean
the five also wins it's you don't have
to you can play a five here and win like
this even if let's say the Knight on D5
demands an exchange sacrifice here is
still much much better in the position
after Knight D5 uh he played Queen C6
instead of Queen B7 and after Bishop G5
he just took on e4 uh yeah undermining
the knife is hanging yeah yeah allowing
this and yeah this should be completely
winning for black yeah I would be saying
that I would be saying that even without
the the engine saying that as well
because
this is a massive massive night which
cannot be shifted Bishop G5 played by
Vincent Kamer uh he wants to play Bishop
D2 I guess what what so what's the
cleanest solution
yeah we go before and after Bishop G2 we
need to
uh to find some kind of a cleanse I
guess you just go rook d8 and just
continue improving yeah exactly I'm a
little bit surprised he allowed H5 yeah
but I guess he just goes maybe maybe he
just goes GH
because honestly I I see absolutely no
reason not to play H5
so that you never even have to you know
have this debate
yeah because you know allowing
allowing H5 H6 here is a way to for the
position to become a little bit trickier
yeah by the way yeah yeah he's gone GH
yeah unsurprisingly yeah GH Bishop c363
on the board he made it to the move 40
but yeah the question is how to win this
in the cleanest possible fashion with
black if you take an infography for a
singing and yeah you can do this but
once again I don't think we won this
with black right now maybe it's winning
maybe it's not yeah but because you're
not sure this is winning despite the
fact that we have an action on the king
side it's not your natural way I mean we
are not sure Magnus might be sure yeah
no such uh such and games I think I know
what he wants and I think this is the
right solution yeah he's gone B3 and
it's not the same end game the
difference being that in this position
I will get my Rook to the side and you
will not get your Rook behind the ball
after Rook D5 there is no way for you to
get the Rook to A7 because I always have
a 40k5 no that's okay that's amazing
yeah and this is winning yeah this is
just winning you've just come with the
King now yeah yeah you just run you just
run to towards the B Pawn and the fact
they have a security of an extra extra
h-pawn here is always going to be
are quite useful yeah Magnus has gone
for this which I assume yeah just the
king comes over to the queen side and
the game ends because you are never
really going to be in time to create
counter play on the other side he just
runs with the King to the the queen side
and
well I mean you you still have to like
the question is what do you do what do
you do in in a situation like this right
yeah you don't want to give this just to
be the question you can postpone you can
postpone this decision for a while by
playing Rooker 5 yourself
but the point is to give and asking why
asking why to spend some time to even
you know line up this attack on F7 like
you'll have to play I'm guessing a three
King the six King three King C6 King E4
uh now important not to blunder this
yeah this would be a bit of a problem
yeah but we go we go Rook G5 I guess and
why it goes I guess back
and yeah we want so much time that I
assume maybe even a four Rook of 783 is
now winning
yeah I mean I don't think much changed I
think the good thing for kymer here is
that he managed to prevent Magnus from
kind of an easy version and he did it in
a kind of a strange way he played a
three King D6 Rook C4 and my question is
my question is why are we not playing
King D5 here I guess King D3 right so
what he's doing now he gave a check on
E5 which I think is
a very useful thing in all of these
kinds of end games where yeah to make
yeah it costs you nothing and it gives
it gives white a choice which is not I
think here's yourself yeah I think here
nobody ever goes king of two I think
king of two is a very strange move to
choose but in general just giving a
check like this is pretty much always
going to be a good idea just to
you know create some uncertainty in the
defender's mind
King D3 and Magnus freedom of King is
six yeah yeah next
and I guess maybe what he wants is now
with the kingdom D3 maybe he wants to go
Rook G5 exactly exactly yeah
and ask if you want to give up on G2 how
do we win this at some point I my guess
is that we'll have to give F the iPhone
now but I wouldn't at all be shocked to
find out ah no no let's lose this yeah
this is ah I mean yeah it's
it's an instructive thing to to realize
yeah that this wins
until Magnus decides what he is going to
give up to start pushing the a pawn
white has no active plan so you can
switch between running this direction
going Rook G5 you can continue switching
between those things for as long as you
like but eventually you have to pick a
side yeah and like if okay G5 first I
could have played yeah I still don't
know what the thread is if we continue
ignoring it but no me too yeah he's gone
Rook G5 I don't know what that signifies
like we've sort of been there does it
make it easier for him to run like like
I mean I'm making bad moves I just want
to like as a kind of a proof of concept
G3 is a kind of a strange decision so
what maybe it doesn't really change very
much I don't know chat also became very
excited about this but I don't know now
it's amazing according to say it's crazy
against anything yeah
yeah no no they can't I think okay and
in the meantime Parham apparently
blundered something horrible and is now
losing okay
in the line we saw move 62 okay one king
H5 and who catch one Rook B5 ah yeah
okay I guess the point is three against
zero is actually very easily winning
yeah
because it provides cover from the
checks from behind I think the
difference is
like we we get some kind of a normal F
and H but that's eventually there will
be no checks from the h file actually
you can hide on H4 or something yeah
which is H4 and which yes he played H4
yeah this is very logical King F2 will
come and now Rook G5 I'm not sure that
after okay one king H5 is the only uh
winning move with five well here I think
maybe H3 wins as well because I I will
be in time to blinking H5 King H4 you
you can do some time that's the last
time it gets extra time except the 37
seconds which it will get till the end
of his life is playing non-stop uh so
but 15 minutes is the last time yeah it
looks like black is just winning because
the king is cut off along the G file and
there is a passer on the H file but it's
tremendously important that white cannot
establish some kind of a defense from
behind here
uh so yeah this is close enough for
Vincent to continue carrying a great
deal about the quality of his decisions
so he's doing the right thing in uh very
much continuing to think and continuing
to calculate but I don't think he saves
this I don't think banks makes a mistake
A8 King H5 King F2 G6 everything is uh
going according to the plan according to
cese H3 is next yeah this is this is
going to be even simpler because uh the
one we were discussing earlier where the
winning plan was to play Ruby 5 here in
this position yeah uh this no longer
applies because the pawn gets to H3 and
once the pawn gets to H3 we just win by
queening that pawn like we play H3 we
play rojito check we play King H [ __ ]
G3 H2 and so on and this cannot be
stopped so I think now
the win is just extremely
straightforward Rook A5 we play Rook G5
Rook goes like anywhere we play H3
uh it really is no longer uh yeah Rook
A3 but we can still play H3 F4 G2 check
it doesn't change anything
a little while I think it will just see
science uh yeah I think I think it's not
a mistake here to just call it quits
because
obviously I think that like everybody
knows I think that Carson
starting from the from the decision to
play C6 here to not enter any of the
theoretical lines uh you know avoid all
of the discussion of the kind of a very
very safe kind of boring Asian games
which you'll never ever win with black